mr schumer thank you so much for being
here first and foremost and also i'm a
master student at price thank you for
standing up for professor moore
absolutely obviously
[Applause]
obviously in light of everything that's
going on at the moment we all believe
rape and sexual assault are heinous
crimes we all want rapes behind bars
but i feel that in this climate logic
evidence
and data are kind of being lost in
translation and also there's
a very pervasive you're with us against
this mentality that's really doing a lot
more harm than good so my question to
you is
how can we best stand up for the
importance of due process and the
presumption of innocence while also
doing what we can to support survivors
okay so i think that uh there's
actually a third question that i want to
address that you didn't even ask i'll
address the first two and then there's a
third one that i think is implicit in
the first two
so when it comes to standing up for due
process the answer is that we actually
have to stand up for it even in cases
where it makes us uncomfortable
or even where we believe that the person
may be responsible for something bad
because once you lose due process for
one you lose due process for everybody
obviously
when it comes to standing up for sexual
assault survivors i think the idea
that we ought to take everybody's
first account with the respect it
deserves
means not dismissing not downplaying but
it also means asking the proper
questions in order to get it true that
doesn't mean intimidating people it
doesn't mean calling people liars
without evidence that they're lying
it doesn't mean mocking them obviously
god forbid it doesn't mean doing any of
those things
you know i've throughout the christine
blasey ford thing i kept i keep saying
over and over and over i'm not calling
her a liar i'm not mocking her
i don't know if she's lying i don't know
if she's telling the truth i don't know
if she's misremembering i don't know any
of that stuff
all i know is the due process requires
such and such to happen
now the the real answer in the end to a
lot of what's happening and here's
here's the really unpopular part with
the left
the left destroyed traditional wars with
regard to relations between the sexes
destroyed them wholesale so the original
idea was that men were supposed to act
with honor and chivalry in protecting
women
and women were supposed to look for for
example
relationships just as men were sexual
activity was supposed to be confined
this was at least the ideal was supposed
to be confined
to committed relationships particularly
marriage
not everybody lived up to that but a
huge number of people did
in fact once people got pregnant people
basically got married
their studies from the 1930s 1940s and
95s shows an awful lot of seven month
marriage babies right people who are
sleeping together getting pregnant and
then
the couple gets married when you don't
teach men to protect
women you get men who will victimize
women and when you don't teach women
that they ought to cherish men who are
responsible and good
all you end up doing is incentivizing
bad male behavior
the feminist movement was not wrong when
they said men are acting like pigs
they were wrong when they said women
also ought to act like pigs and that
this is a solution to our problem
because the reverse because now what's
happened is they got rid of all the
traditional moors about how
sex ought to be connected with love and
not to be connected with relationships
they got rid of all of that it was just
a bodily
function now except except when it comes
to actual sexual assault we treat that
differently than any other bodily
function obviously
but that's the problem right so they
create the standard where sex is
basically a throwaway item sort of like
eating
and then we treat sex very differently
when it comes to
what we all know it is which is a deeply
important and intimate part of a
person's life
and then we attempt to back door
standards of consent
that frankly don't make any sense in a
real-life context so you get college
campuses in california saying that what
you need
is a yes means yes standard where you
have like a first
like a legal checklist i guess where
every time you do anything in the
bedroom you're supposed to ask am i
allowed to touch your hand am i allowed
to touch your shoulder might touch your
hair
which has never ever resulted in actual
fulfillment of a sexual
encounter right i mean it's just it's
it's sort of like it's like zeno's
paradox if you have a yes means yes
standard the closer you get the further
away you are
and the
the the ria and again sex is this is
this is where
women really gave up on marriage a lot
too soon okay marriage was the best
thing
ever for women it is an amazing it's an
amazing thing for men too because it
civilizes them it cultures them it
teaches them to be protectors of their
family and to take care of people and to
think beyond themselves and to think
beyond their generation
women gave up in marriage a way to teach
men to do those things
and also women gave up the idea that a
commitment was going to come along with
this intimacy
and let's be real about this i mean
every scientific study ever done has
shown that women actually do have better
sex in the context of committed
relationships
all of the crap that you see in cosmo
magazine about sleeping with 100 guys
and being sexually happy
is just garbage it is just sheer
unadulterated garbage
[Applause]
so no long answer to a short question
but reinculcation of traditional roles
of male and female
with the same feminist respect that we
ought to have for women at all steps of
the process is the answer